Before this video blehgins
Are you not on a VPN right now brah?
Are you seriously telling me...
That you're not taking the advantage of this
Brand... new... epic... opportunity?
Where you don't get just 25% off...
Not 50% off...
But 75 GODDAMN PERCENT off?
If you sign up for NordVPN
With a three-ee year plan
Using the code PEWDIEPIE
Where you get AN EXTRA MONTH for freeeeee?
"But Felix I don't need a VPN" - YAH YOU DO!
All your data could be stolen
Just think about that for a second...
Think about those websites...
What if people were to find out?
With a VPN, whatever you're doing online should be safe
If you ever connect to a public WiFi without a VPN
And you log in to literally anything
Whether it's your bank, social media, emails
That could all get breached EASILY
Everyone should have a VPN
And right now, if you sign up for NordVPN
You don't only just dodge and YEET on Article 13
Which is now called Article 14
This is Article 13 when you have a VPN
"But I can't afford it" It's $2.99 a month!
And that's a great price!
Check out the link in the description zsupport the channel as well
Thank you very much - on with the video!
*magical chime*
Le-
Let's look at the top memes this week SON
It's all gonna be Keanu stuff
The week of Keanu
*Reading meme*
*Laughs*
We've all been there, let's get real
*Reading meme*
Omedetou gozaimasu
M- Mr Beast-san
This is what the top voted thing on my subreddit is...
OK, alright, sure
*Reading out the meme onscreen*
*laughs*
I was debating if I should just pretend that I'm speaking Swedish
'Cos no one's gonna know if I do that or not
But I also know Swedish people are a bunch of ***holes
And they will correct me anyway
I love this - Keanu Reeves, and then apparently Elon Musk middle name is Reeves
PRAISE THE REEVES!
HALLELUJAH!
*Reading meme*
Oh my God I- HhOHhOHhoHoh
That is AWESOOOME
Look at Edgar!
EDGAAAAAAAR!
It's so cuuuhuhuhuhute!
*inhale*
Ma- Marzia's sitting on the chair!
That is awesome!
*Reading meme*
Nani?... What a - neeh... no... no
Amazing job... a meme animation, I haven't seen that before. Well done.
Thank you very much a2wayrod
*Reading meme*
*Laughs quietly*
Why is this meme still going? - I thought I killed it
I thought I fired them
*Starts reading* Oh God.. oh right, yep
Nice kill, good game - that's right, that's what I *laughs*
Why's this also still going on?
*Reading meme*
GoDdAmN
You guys thought resurrecting from the dead wasn't cool? Well CHECK THIS OUT *Laughs*
*Reading meme*
*paHA*
Why is this funny, it's not funny
AYY ANOTHER ONE
*Reading meme*
Finmally someone did something with this uh... meme template
"Felix in 2080p60 frames per second for the first time"
Me
Come on, the quality is good now, we need to drop this meme, please
"Proof that - goddamnit!"
"Pewds was born in 144p"
Imagine seeing me in real life- OH GOD!
THE QUALITY!
*Laughs*
*Reading meme*
"Having a three ninety-niiiiiiiiiine chair"
Having TWO 399 chairs, and a half
Was that - the right math?
*Reading meme*
Why is there... a me - oh, okay
*Laughs and continues reading meme*
What happened in 2009?
It was such a weird... year of memes, man
*Chuckles* Also 2019... BEEEANS!!!
"Why am I losing subscribers?"
Oh, my God. Can you guys not obsess about every single little detail in my videos, please? Okay?
This is an EXTENGSION, okay?
It only... Philips Hue is a cheap-ass company, and that only make them this far
And if you wanna make them further you need to attach this EUH-extension thing
Which leaves a little GAP IN IT!
Alright, it's not MY FAULT!!
What can I put there?
To make up for it?
Maybe I got the extension wrong...
No..
"I cannot... I seriously didn't understand anything he said in the video"
"Because I kept looking at the gaaaaap"
"Look at the gap - like, why is there a gap there??"
"Can someone explain to me, WHY THERE'S A GAP THERE???"
"UH- WHY ISN'T THE FRAME PERFECTLY FRAMED - EEEEEE  EEEEEEEEEEEE"
That's how you sound like
Is there anything I can put there?
My 399 controller - how does gravity work?
what
Alright I'll figure it out!
*Reading meme*
F - Oh, I get it
Yeees
*Reading meme*
What?
I cracked the code... okay, sure
*Reading meme*
"All the way back" - two years ago
Guys, I don't know whaaat he's talking about... this is not...
*Strange noise*
*Reading meme*
Well he is in the game, and I do actually wanna play Cyberpunk
Okay alright, let's calm down, alright... I am not Mary Ham
If I was Mary Ham, then how can I speak with such perfect Swedish?
"Hallo, it's me Pewdiepee *pewdeepee* *no idea what he says*"
*Reading meme*
That's because wha- that's what heroes do
I didn't even bring this up in my Keanu video, I just thought it's like... okay
So you're saying that anyway that grabs the waist or arm of a girl... is bad?
Like, you have to do this to be good?
It doesn't make sense to me, I- I don't understand this
*Tries to read the meme but laughs*
Oh, God, whadahhda- EGH, I can't have *AH* one more video putting Keanu Reeves in the goddamn thumbnail
*Reading meme*
Honestly?
Crazy
*Reading meme*
Come on! You win EVERY TIME in Crainiac, it's NOT A SCAM
WHAAAT? BWAHAHA
*Reading meme*
"What you didn't play Tuber Simulator?"
This is before and after
*Reading meme*
YouTube Gaming
YouTube Gaming, unbelievable... unsupporter
*Reading meme*
There's some good memes this week, well done
That's -that's clever
Look at even the... the gun
Goddamn
*Reading meme*
Oh... my... God
ohmygod
*Reading meme*
Stop taking pictures with Keanu Reeves!!
Let him live his life Goddamnit!
Oh yeah Lush changed it
So awesome
Thank you Lush, very cool - G FUEL package incoming
*Reading meme*
I just dream about dying
Nothing else
*Reading meme*
WHAAAAT!!?!?
bruuuuuuuh...
Well yeah, pretty much
*Reading meme*
"Wow!"
*Naughty Swedish words*
*Reading meme*
Awwwww
This is what I like, well done
*Reading meme*
Hey! Someone made a meme out of the game, well done
Very epic
*Reading meme*
Felix in real life
AAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
*Reading meme*
What is that?
What is that thing?
Aw, that's awesome - Edgarry Night
It's beautiful!
Thank you!
*Reading meme*
I would love to see something with them collaborating
100% agree - and if a video is claimed by someone else, it should show
A lot of times we get demonetized, and ads are still rolled on the video
But it doesn't show that the ads isn't actually supporting the creator
It's actually going in the pocket of someone else
I think that's an important distinction at least, that people should be aware about
Ahah... I think I know where this is going...
"Posting meme normally"
"Posting inverted memes so they appear normally in Pewds' mirror" *laughter*
Can you see it?
That's so cool
No you really can't
Well boys, we did it
Well now I'm blurry, I gotta stand over here
Alright guys, thanks for watching another episode of LWIAY
Smash like, subscribe, let's get the 100 million Goddamnit, come on, we can't stop now!
Subscribe
And epically... see you tomorrow!
Thanks for all the memes... BYE!
*eerie silence beyond words*
WHAT!? You've seen this ad so many times I don't need to give subtitles? Cool! Now download Tuber Simulator! You know it's... fun, right? :D